now i i didn't even want to do this
today
but i sort of um i sort of have to
because there is a problem
in the progressive community sam cedar
host of the majority report with sam
cedar and other shows with sam cedar is
uh doubling down on his allegation that
something is wrong
with the growth that our youtube channel
is experiencing now two weeks ago we
reached
900 000 subscribers on our youtube
channel
and i announced a race against the clock
meaning i i wasn't involving anybody
else i wasn't assailing anyone's
character i wasn't disparaging anybody's
work i was challenging myself and you i
was challenging the audience
can we get to a million youtube
subscribers by election day
at the time i said it we were projected
by socialblade which is a website that
tracks this sort of thing
to get to a million subscribers by
january 9.
we were scheduled to miss election day
thanks to your support over the last two
weeks
the growth curve has accelerated and
instead of january 9th instead of
december we are now
scheduled to get to a million
subscribers on november 23rd
which means we're down to just 20 20
more days that we can move that up and
we will hit
a million by election day well sam cedar
who's also in this kind of area between
900 000 and a million subscribers
he seems to think i'm cheating he seems
to think i'm doing something wrong and
he suggested last week that i might be
using bots
or some other kind of uh mechanism
elements of cheating
for lack of a better term to get to a
million subscribers
he's fallen a bit behind in the race
okay
and he's now lashing out he's doubling
down on these wild claims
he actually seems a little bit unhinged
check this out and remember
we're just kidding around this is all in
good fun remember uh that that this
you don't actually have to email me or
him about this but
take a look at what sam said bear at
home too
great seeing you on msnbc over the
weekend where can i find the full
episode online so i can send it to my
mom
also you're doing an impression of chris
hayes your cadence seem very familiar
i like the old matt on thursdays can you
interview david pakman on one of the
shows
uh we're in a big war right now with
david pakman i don't know if people know
that so
no way no way
what if he gives you views by being on
gotta
see this stuff yeah jiu-jitsu well you
know with the way pac-man works you just
come on to steal subscribers
so that that's a pretty low blow
i don't have a history of stealing
anything and by the way this is not zero
sum you know you can subscribe to his
channel and mine
sam's problem is he's operating in the
paradigm of a zero-sum world where
you're either
subscribed to him or subscribe to me he
thinks if i get a subscriber
i've taken something from him that's
maybe rightfully his or something like
that
people can subscribe to both of us
there's no way to steal subscribers and
this diatribe and screed actually
continued
you know the way pac-man works he'd just
come on to steal subscribers
i know the way that he's what he's up to
can we get into this
right now this is like i want i've been
trying to hold off on this but
there's something fishy going on we're
going to do a deep deep dive into this
at one point with david pakman's
subscriber numbers because
you know normally subscriber numbers go
like this
all right they normally go like this
that's the normal graph of subscriber
numbers
okay it's also my notes to myself here
wait a second let me do this
let me tell you what has happened with
uh david pakman's numbers
they have gone like this something very
fishy is going on
that is not a normal subscriber grab
it's ben shapiro's way to sabotage you
he's like
getting it on there well i don't know
what it is but i will tell you this
i suggested very lightly
very lightly that maybe there were bots
at play
and then all of a sudden i get a bunch
of emails
saying i'm not a bot but they oh
but they all are clearly sent from bots
look at let's play this yeah look at
that look at what
what's going on there i'm sorry folks
like what is what is that about
there's something going on i think
somebody should investigate this
so this is um i i hate to say it but
this is very trumpian of sam this is a
post hoc rationalization
sam is first looking at subscriber
growth on my channel
and then he is after the fact coming up
with an explanation that points to
subterfuge it points to something
untoward
it can't just be hey people are
connecting with the content and they're
subscribing that couldn't possibly be it
it can't be if our growth is faster than
sam's
i must be cheating and this got even
uglier
well do we have a clip of when he uh he
as far as i can tell he got his
subscribers because he attacked me let's
play this clip here
listen um how do we even do this
things are getting really ugly in the
progressive media space
and it pains me to have to do this today
but sam cedar has
casually made a disgusting claim
about the david david pakman show and
fired
a shot across the bow about our recent
surge of subscribers
claiming absent any evidence mind you
that somehow bots
that i have presumably used or paid for
are boosting our youtube subscriber
numbers
let me give you a little background last
week by the way this is all a joke just
because i know people will
this is all a joke okay last week okay
stop it the david pakman show him
now what is he what is he doing there
he's trying to play it off like it's all
a joke
that's crazy he's suing him huh this
well i mean i'm i'm i'm not suing him
but i am going to look and see if
there's any type of um
a i mean did pacman sitting there
basically calling me a joke
right didn't he just say it's all a joke
i think he's worried that you might go
off the deep end and sue him really like
you never know you could snap any minute
and just
send him a cease and desist shut down
the show better be careful
here's my challenge david pakman okay he
just accused me of being a joke
right like the whole video is about he
just said this is
this is all a joke referring to me and
so
um i as far as i'm concerned that's
uh is that liable or defamation it's
defamation right when you say it when
you say it as opposed to libels written
is that right now i i know you guys are
too smart to be goaded into some kind of
conflict here
you all see what's going on i see what's
going on we're not going to fall for it
these bizarre
semantic games philosophical black holes
that people are getting we're just not
going to bite what is this what is what
is the subscriber count
data experts look into it what is the
subscriber count at it now
9 32 9 32
the guys added like 30 000 subscribers
in like a week
we're down 17th oh 15 i thought
we were tied with him two weeks ago
oh this is bad this is really bad
so there you hear what this is really
about
you hear that in sam's voice right there
is a frustration there
that is being taken out on me it's being
taken out
on you as one of my viewers or listeners
you were called a bot
so this we cannot allow join
the david pakman show youtube channel
join
the pacman to 1 million by election day
2020 campaign subscribe today it's free
but in reality let's get multiple shows
on the progressive left to a million
subscribers you all know what to do